okay let's get
so welcome to lecture number four today
we will go over two topics that are not
discussed in the Coursera videos you've
been learning c 2 m 1 and c 2 m 2 if I'm
not mistaking so you've learnt about
what an initialization is how to tune
your own networks what tests validation
and trainsets
are today we're going to go a little
further you should have the background
to understand 80% of this lecture
there's maybe 20% that I want you to
look back after you've seen the batch
norm videos for those of you who haven't
seen them
so we'll fit the lecture in two parts
and I put back the attendance code at
the at the very end of the lecture so
don't worry
one topic is attacking neural networks
with adversarial examples the second one
is generative adversarial networks and
although these two topics have a common
word which is adversarial there are two
separate topics you will understand why
it's called adversarial in both cases so
let's get started with adversarial
examples and in 2013 a Christian Zagat
in his team have published a paper
called intriguing properties of neural
networks what they noticed is that
neural net was neural networks have kind
of a blind spots a spot for which
several machine learning including the
state-of-the-art ones that you will
learn about vgg 1619 inception networks
and residual networks are vulnerable to
something called adverse early examples
these adverse early examples you're
going to learn what it is in three parts
first by explaining how these examples
in the context of images can attack a
network in their blind spot and and make
the network classify these images as
something totally wrong how to defend
against this type of examples and why
are networks
vulnerable to this type of examples this
is a little bit more theoretical and
we're going to go over it on the board
the papers that are listed on the bottom
or the two big papers that started this
field of research so I would advise you
to go and and read them because we have
only one hour and a half to go over two
big topics in in deep learning and we
will not have the time to go into
details of everything
okay so let's set up the goal the goal
is like is that given a pre trained
network so a network trained on imagenet
on a thousand classes millions of images
find an input image that is not an
iguana
so doesn't look like the animal iguana
but will be classified by the network as
an iguana we will call this an
adversarial example if we manage to find
it okay yeah one question so 2848 89 let
me write it down on the board can you
guys see okay that's more so we have a
network pre trained on Imogen it's a
very good network what I want is to fool
it by giving it an image that doesn't
look like anyone a bird is classified as
an iguana so if I give it a cat image to
start with the network is obviously
going to give me a vector of
probabilities that has the maximum
probability for cats because it's a good
network and you can guess what's the
output layer of this network is probably
a soft max it's a classification network
now what I want is to find an image x
that is going to be classified as an
iguana by the network okay
does the the setting make sense to
everyone okay now as usual this this
might remind you of what we've seen
together about neural style transfer
remember the art generation thing where
we wanted to generate an image based on
the content of a first image and the
style of another image and in that
problem the main difference with classic
supervised learning was that we fix the
parameters of the network which was also
pre trained
and we back propagate the error of the
loss all the way back to the input image
to update the pixels so that it looks
like the content of the contents image
and the style of the style image the
first thing we did is that we rephrase
the problem we try to phrase what
exactly we want so what would you say is
a sentence that defines our last
function let's say yes an image that
provides minimum cost ok what's the cost
you're talking about expected iguana and
not expected iguana what do you mean
exactly by that we're trying to Train it
yeah okay
so you want this image to minimize a
certain loss function and the loss
function would be the distance metric
between the output you're looking for
and the output you want okay yeah so I
would say we want to find X the image
that Y hat of X which is the result of
the forward propagation of X in the
network is equal to Y iguanas which is a
one hard vector with the one at the
position of iguanas
does that make sense so now based on
that we define our loss function which
is can be an l2 loss can be an l1 loss
can be a croissant repea in practice
this one works better so you see that
minimizing this loss function will lead
our image X to be outputted as an iguana
by the network that makes sense and then
the process is very similar to neural
side transfer where we will optimize the
image iteratively so we will start with
X we will forward propagate it compute
the loss function that we just defined
and remember we're not training the
network right which
take the derivative of the loss function
all the way back to the inputs and
update the input using a graduate
descent algorithm until we get something
that is classified as anyone yeah any
question on that okay so you mentioned
that it doesn't warranty that X is not
going to look like something the only
thing is guaranteeing is that this X
will be classified as an iguana if we
trained properly we will talk about that
now another question in the back I
thought yeah oh yeah it could be binary
croissant it could be croissant repiy
yeah so in this case not binary
cross-entropy because we have a vector
of of n classes but it could have been
croissant from here okay so yeah that's
true we are we Goren T that's the forged
image X this one is going to look like
an iguana who thinks it's going to look
like an iguana a few who thinks it's not
going to look like anyone okay majority
of you so can someone tell me why it's
not going to look like an iguana
okay so you say the loss function is
unconstrained is very unconstrained so
we didn't put any constraint on what the
image should look like that's true
actually the answer to this question is
it depends
we don't know maybe it looks like an
iguana maybe does it but in terms of
probabilities it's high chance that it
doesn't look like anyone so the reason
is here let's say this is our space of
input images an interesting thing is
that even if as human on a daily basis
we deal with images of the real world so
like I mean if you look at the TV
that is totally buggy you see pixels
random pixels but in other contexts we
usually see real word distribution
images our network is deterministic it
means it takes an image any input image
that fits the the first layer would
would be would produce an output right
so this is the whole space of input
images that the network can see this is
the space of real images it's a lot
smaller can someone tell me what's the
size of the the space of possible input
images for a network so infinite it's
not infinite it's been a lot but okay
yeah there is an idea here someone here
is number impossible pixel permutations
yeah that's true
so more precisely you would start with
how many pixel values are there there
are 255 256 pixel values and then what's
the size of an image let's say 64 by 64
by 3 and your results would give you 256
so you fix the first pixel 256 possible
value then the second one can be
anything else then the third one can be
anything else
and you end up with a very big number so
this is a huge number and the space of
real images is here now if we had to
plot the space of of images classified
as an iguana it would be something like
that right and you see that there is a
small overlap between the space of real
images and the space of him
is classified by as an iguana by the
network and this is where we probably
are not we're probably in the green part
that is not overlapping with the red
part because we didn't constrain our
optimization problem does that make
sense okay now we're going to constrain
it a little bit more because in practice
this type of attacks are not too
dangerous because as a human we would
see that the pictures look like garbage
the dangerous attack is if the picture
looks like a cat but the network sees it
as an iguana and humans see it as a cat
can someone think of of like malicious
applications of that face recognitions
you could show a face you could show
your your picture of your face I'll push
the network to think it's a face of
someone else what else yeah breaking
CAPTCHAs if you know what the output
what output you want you can force the
network to think that this CAPTCHA did
this input CAPTCHA is the output it's
looking for or in general I would say
like social medias if someone is
malicious and wants to put violent
content online there is all these
companies have algorithms to check for
this violent content if people can use
adverse you're examples that look still
violent but are not detected as violent
by the algorithms using this methodology
they could still publish their violent
pictures think about self-driving cars a
stop sign that looks like a stop sign
for everyone but when the self-driving
car sees it it's not a stop sign so
these are malicious applications of
adversity examples and they're a lot
more okay and in fact the picture we
generated previously would look like
that it's nothing special
so now let's constrain our problem a
little bit more we're going to say we
want the picture to look like a cat but
be classified as an iguana okay so now
same we have our neural network if we
give it a cat is going to predict that
it's a cat what we want is
she'll give it a cut but predict that
it's only one okay III go quickly over
that because it's very similar to what
we did before so I just plot I just put
back what we had on the previous slide
okay exactly the same thing now the way
we phrase our problem will be a little
different instead of saying we want only
y hat of x equals y y now we have
another constraint what's the other
constraint the picture X should be
closer to the picture of the cat so we
want X equal or very close to X cat and
in terms of loss function what it does
is that it adds another term which is
going to decide how X should be close to
X cat if we minimize this loss now we
should have an image that looks like a
cat because of the second term and that
is predicted as an iguana because of the
first term does that make sense
so we're just building up our loss
functions and I guess you guys are very
familiar with this type of thought
process now okay an same process we
optimized until we hopefully get a cat
now a question is what should be the
initial image we start with we didn't
talk about that in the previous example
yeah
white noise well yeah possibly white
noise any other a cat
yeah which cat
I don't know probably the cat that we
put in the last function right because
it's the closest one to what we want to
get so if we want to have a fast process
we'd better start with exactly this cat
which is the one we put in our last
function here right if we put another
cat is going to be a little longer
because we have to change the pixel of
the other cat to look like this cat
that's what we told our last function if
we start with white noise it will take
even longer because we have to change
the pixels all the way so that it looks
real and then it looks like a cat that
we defined here so yeah the best thing
would be probably to start with the
picture of the cat does that make sense
and then move the pixels so that this
term is also minimized yeah yeah this is
this is empirical the fact that we use
that type of loss function but in
practice it could have been any distance
between X and X cat and any distance
between you I hurt my cat yeah and why
you go on Oscar yes
exactly it's a bunch of cats I'm not
sure about the second method but just to
repeat the point you mentioned is that
here we had to choose a cat
it means the X cat is actually an image
of a cat so what if we don't know what
the cat should look like we just want a
random cat to come out and be classified
as an iguana we're going to see a
generative networks after which can be
used to do that type of stuff but but
for the second part of the question I'm
not sure what the optimization process
would look like okay
let's move on so yeah it's probably a
good idea to start with the cat image
that we specified in the last function
okay and so then we have an image of a
cat that originally was classified as
92% cat and we modified a few pixels so
you can see that this image looks a
little blurry
so by doing this modification the
network will think it's an iguana okay
and sometimes this modification can be
very slight and we can even not be able
to notice it sounds good
now let's add something else to this to
this to this draft we add a third set
which is the space of images that look
real to human so that's interesting
because the space of images that look
real to human is actually bigger the
space than the space of real images an
example is this one this is probably an
image that looks real to human but it's
not an image that we could seen in the
daily life because of this slight pixel
changes okay so these are the space of
dangerous are there examples they look
real to human but they're not actually
real they might be used to fool model
okay
now let's see a video by cracking at all
on real world example of adversity all
examples so for those who cannot read
they're taking a camera which which
classify which has a classifier and the
classifier classifies the first part as
the library and the second image that is
that the same as a prison
so the second image has slight different
pixels but it's hard to see for him same
here
so the the classifier on the phone
classifies the first image as a washer
with fifty-two percent accuracy
confidence and the second one as a
doormat so this is a small example of
what can what can be done okay now let's
go we've seen how to generate these
adverse real examples it's an
optimization process we will see what
are the type of attacks that we can lead
and what are defenses against these
adverse all examples so we would usually
split the attacks into two parts non
targeted attacks and targeted attacks so
non targeted attacks means that we just
want output we just want to find an
adversary example that is going to fool
the model while targeted attack is we
want to force this ad versatile example
to be output to output a specific class
that we chose these are two different
type of attacks that that are widely
discussed in in the research knowledge
of the attacker is something very
important for those of you who did some
crypto you know that we talk about white
box attacks black box attacks so one
interesting thing is that a black box
attack a white box attack is when you
have access to a network so we have our
image and pretend free train network we
have fully access to to all the
parameters and the gradients so it's
probably an easier attack right we can
we can back propagate all the way back
to the image and update the image like
with it
box attack is when the model is probably
encrypted or something like that so that
we don't have access to its parameters
activations and architecture so the
question is how do we attack in blackbox
attack if we cannot back propagates
because we don't have access to the
layers any ideas yeah numerical grade
yeah good idea
so you know you will trick the image a
little bit and you will see how it
changes the laws looking at this you can
you can do have an estimate of the
numerical gradient even if the model is
a black box model this assumes that you
can query the model right you can query
it what if you cannot even query the
model or you can query it one time only
it's to send you add virtual example how
would you do that so this becomes more
complicated
so there is a very complex property of
this address your example is is that
they're highly transferable it means I
have a model here that is a nanny Moll
classifier okay I don't have access to
it I cannot even query it I still want
to fool it what I'm going to do is that
I'm going to build my own animal
classifier forge an adversarial example
on it it's highly likely that it's going
to be an adverse example for the other
one as well so this is called
transferability and it's still a
research topic okay we're trying to
understand why this happens and also how
to defend against that you know maybe
your defense against that is - is -
we're going to see it after I'm not
going to say enough so does that make
sense or no this transferability
probably it's because - animal
classifiers look at the same features in
images right and maybe these pixels that
are playing we're playing with or
changing also the output of the other
network let's go over some kind of
defenses so one solution to defend
against these adversely networks is to
create a safe safety net a safety net is
what is a net that like a firewall you
will put it before your network every
image that comes in will be classified
as fake like forged or real by the
network and you only take those which
are real and not not adversarial does
that make sense so you could you could
you could say that okay but we can also
build an adversarial Network that that
fools this network right just we beat
black box or white box we can just
create an adversary at example for this
network it's true but the issue is that
now we have two constraints we have to
fool the first one and the second one at
the same time you know maybe if you fool
the first one there is a chance that the
second one is going to be fooled we
don't know okay
it just makes it more complex there is
no good defense at this point - -
to all type of adversarial examples this
is an option that people are researching
for so the paper is here if you want to
check it out can you guys think of
another solution trained on multiple
loss functions through different
networks so you're talking about an
assembly maybe we can maybe we can
create five networks to do our tasks and
it's highly unlikely that the address on
that example is going to fool the file
networks the same way right
any other ideas generates adversarial
examples and trained on those okay so
you will generate a cat image that is
adversarial so some pixels have been
changed to full a network you will label
it as the human sees it so as a cat
because you want the network to still
see that as a cat and you will train on
those the downside of that is that it's
very costly we've seen that generating
adversarial examples is super custom and
also we don't know if we can generalize
to other adversary examples maybe we're
going to overfit to the ones we have so
it's another optimization problem now
another solution is to train on add
virtual examples at the same time as we
train on on normal examples so look at
this loss function this loss function
the loss new is a sum of two loss
functions one is the classic loss
function we would use so let's say
croissant repiy in the case of
classification and the second one is the
same loss function but we give it the
adversary genomics so what's the
complexity of that at a very gradient
descent step
[Applause]
for every iteration of our gradient
descent we're going to have to iterate
enough to forge an adversarial example
at every step right because we have X
what we want to do is forward propagate
X to the network to compute the first
term generate X adversarial with the
optimization process and forward
propagate it to calculate the second
term and then back propagate over the
weights of the network these super
costly as well and it's very similar to
what you said is just online just all
the time
ok so what is interesting is we're going
to delve a little more there's another
technique called logic pairing I just
put it here we're not going to talk
about it there's a paper here if you
want to check it it's another way to do
adversarial training but what I would
like to talk about is more from a
theoretical perspective why our neural
network vulnerable to adversarial
examples so let's let's do some some
work on the board yeah the noise thing
is also nice but you you so the thing is
that it's just like in crypto every time
you come up with a defense someone will
come up with an attack and it's a race
between humans you know so this is the
same type of problem security problems
are ok so let's go over something
interesting that is more on the in on
the intuition side of adverse early
examples so let me let me write down
something so one question we asked
ourselves is why do adversity an example
exists
what's the reason and young good fellow
and and and his team have came up with
explaining with the the one of the
seminal papers of adversity examples
where they argue that although many
people in the past have have attributed
these existence of adversity examples to
high nonlinear non-linearity zuv neural
networks and overfitting
so because we over
it to a specific data set we actually
don't understand what cats are we just
understanding what what we've been
trained on they argue that it's actually
the linear parts of networks that is the
cause of the existence of adversary
examples so let's see why and the
example I'm going to I'm going to look
at is linear regression so together with
similar gistic regression linear
regression is basically the same thing
without the sigmoid so before the
sigmoid we have Y hat equals W X plus B
so the for propagation of our network is
going to be Y hat equals W X plus B okay
and our first example is going to be a
six dimensional input okay we have a
neuron here but the neuron doesn't have
any activation because we're in linear
regression so here what happens is
simply w8 plus B okay and then we get Y
hats and we probably use an l1 or l2
loss because it's a regression problem
to to train this network now let's look
at the first example a first example
where where X where we strained our
network so network has been trained so
network has been trained and converged
to W equals 1/3 minus 1 2 to 3 this is w
and you know like because we defined X
to be a vector of size is a column
vector W has to be a row vector of size
so the network converts to this value of
W and B equals zero so now we're going
to look at this input we're giving a new
input to the network and then the input
is going to be 1 minus 1 to 0 3 minus 2
ok so I'm going to 4 propagate this to
get Y hat equals W X plus B and this
value is going to be 1 times 1 minus 3
minus 2 plus 0 plus 6 minus 6 if I
didn't make a mistake
up up 2 minus 3
okay and so we we basically get minus 4
ok so this is the the first the first
example that was propagated now the
question is how to change X into X star
such that Y hat changes radically but X
star is close to X so this is basically
our problem but we're still examples can
we find an example that is very close to
X but radically radically changes the
output of our network and we're trying
to build intuition on adversarial
networks
so the interesting part is to is to
identify how we should modify X and the
intuition comes from the derivative if
you take the derivative of Y hat with
respect to X you know that the
definition of this term is is like
correlated to the impact on Y hat of
small changes of X right how what's the
impact of small changes of X to on the
output and if you compute it what do you
get W everybody agrees what's the shape
of this thing shape of that is the same
as shape of X so it should be W
transpose remember derivative of a
scalar with respect to a vector is the
shape of the vector okay now it's
interesting to to see this because if we
compute X star to be let's say X plus a
small perturbation like I will call it
perturbation value yeah sorry and can
you see the top one listen yes or no
so what if X star equals x plus epsilon
time w transpose you know and this
epsilon I will call it value of the
perturbation now if we for propagate X
star it means we do y hat star equals W
X star plus B but B is 0 at this point
we're going to get W X plus epsilon W
times W transpose and W times W
transpose is a dot product right so this
is the same as W squared so what is
interesting it's interesting because the
smart part was that this term is always
going to be positive it means we removed
a little bit X because we can make this
change little by changing epsilon to a
small value but it's going to push Y hat
to a larger value for sure you know and
if I had a minus here instead of a plus
it would push Y hat to a smaller value
and the interesting thing is now if we
compute X star to be X plus epsilon
times W transpose and we take epsilon to
be a small value like let's say point
two you can make the calculation what we
get is is this so 1 minus 1/2 0 3 minus
2 plus 0.2 times 1 0.2 times 3 minus 0.2
plus 0.4 plus 0.4 and
zero point six so if you look at that
all the positive values have been pushed
on the right degree and all the negative
values sorry sorry no that's my way
no that's sorry so let's finish the
calculation and I'll give the inside
after one point to a minus zero point
four one point eight zero point four
three point four and minus one point
four so this is our X star that we hope
to be adversarial
okay let's compute y hat star to see
what happens it's W X star plus B which
is zero so what we get when we multiply
W by X star is 1.2 1.2 minus one point
two minus one point eight plus zero
point eight plus six point eight and
minus 4.2 which I believe is going to
give us zero point five okay so we see
that a very slight change in X star has
pushed Y hat from minus 4 to point 5 and
so a few things we want to notice here
so insights on this on this small
example the first one is that if W is
large then X star is not similar to X
right the larger the W the less X star
is is likely to be like X and
specifically if one entry of the a value
is very large X I the pixel
corresponding to this entry is going to
be very different from X I star if W is
large X star is going to be different
than X so what we're going to do is that
we're going to take sine sine of W
instead of taking W what's the reason
why we do that because the interesting
part is the sine of of the W it means if
we play correctly with the sign of W we
will always push the X this term W X
star in the positive side because every
entry here this multiplication is going
to give us a positive number right and
the second insight is that as X grows in
dimension the impact of plus Epsilon
sign of W increases that makes sense
so the impact of sign of W on white hats
increases and so what's interesting to
notice is that we can keep epsilon as
small as possible it means X and X star
will be very similar but as we grow in
dimension we're going to get more term
in this a lot more term and the change
in Y hat is going to grow and grow and
grow and grow and grow and so the one
reason why adversity all examples exist
for images is because the dimension is
very high 64 by 64 by 3 so we can make
epsilon very small and take the sign of
W we will still get Y hat to be far from
the original value that it had does it
make sense do you guys have any question
on that so epsilon doesn't grow with the
dimension but its impact of this term
increases with the dimension okay to a
cooler I think who's watching - I know -
included I think what's what into what
but wait in between these gives you a
map it to another can't eat this okay so
you like you try to earn adversarially
yeah I I don't know if that's has been
done I don't think that has been done so
you're talking about taking a little
coder that takes the adverse an example
to convert you to a normal image of the
cat and then give the cat maybe yeah I
don't know so it's a topic of research
okay let's move on because we don't have
too much time so just to conclude what
we're going to count as a general way to
generate adversely examples is this
formula this is going to be a fast way
to generate adversary example so this
method is called the phase fast gradient
sign method so basically what we're
doing is that we can we're linearizing
the cost function in in the proximity of
the parameters and we're saying that
what applied to linear networks here is
going to also apply for this general
formula for deeper networks so we're
pushing the pixel images in one
direction that is going to impact highly
the output okay so that's the intuition
behind it now you might say that okay we
did this example on a linear network but
neural networks are not linear they're
highly nonlinear in fact if you look
where the research has been going for
the past few years we're trying to
linearize all the behaviors of these
neural networks with value for example
or width of your initialization all that
type of methods even a sigmoid when we
train on sigmoid we do all we can to put
sigmoid in the linear regime because we
want fast training okay and one last
thing that I'll mention for adversary'
examples
is if I have a network like this so
fully connected with three-dimensional
inputs up yeah and then one here and
then the output what's interesting is
computing the chain rule on this neuron
will give you that derivative of the
loss function with respect to let's say
X is equal to the derivative of the loss
function with respect to Z 1 1 here
times derivative of Z 1 1 with respect
to X let's see where we're going we're
going there's actually a summation here
but anyway just let me illustrate the
point what we're what we're saying is
that what we're what we try to do with
neural networks is to have these
gradients be high because if this
gradient is not high we're not able to
train the parameters of this neuron and
we need this gradient to be high because
if you want to do the same thing with
the we W 1 1 which is the parameters
related to this neuron you would need to
go to this Traynham correct so we need
this gradient to be high and if this
gradient is high the gradient with
respect to the input is also going to be
high because you use the same gradient
in the chain rule so networks that are
that have high gradients and that are
operating in the linear regime or even
more vulnerable to adverse real examples
because of this observation so any
question on adversarial examples before
we move on I think we don't have time
and I would like to to go over the gans
with you guys so let's move on to guns
I'll stick around to answer questions on
that part so the general question we're
asking now is do neural networks
understand
the data because we've seen that some
some data points look like there would
be real but the neural networks don't
understand it so more generally can we
build generate these networks that can
mimic the real world distribution of
images let's say and this is what we
will call generative address all at work
we'll start by motivating it and then we
look at something called the minimax
game between two networks a generator
and a discriminator that are going to
help each other improve and finally we
will see that gans are hard to train
we'll see some tips to train them and
finally go over some nice results and
methods to evaluate ganz ok so the
motivation behind generative iverson
networks is to endow computers with an
understanding of our world ok so by by
that we mean that we want to collect a
lot of data use it to train a model that
can generate images that look like
they're real even if they're not so a
dog that has never existed can be
generated by this network and finally
the number of parameters of the model is
smaller than the amount of data we
already talked about that and this is
the intuition behind why a generative
network can exist is because there is
too much data in the world any images
count as the data for generative network
and there are not enough parameters to
mimic this data you know you have the
network needs to understand the salient
features of the data set because it
doesn't have enough parameter to overfit
everything so let's talk about
probability distributions so these are
samples from real images that have been
taken and if you plot this real data
distribution in a 2d map it would look
like something like that I made it up
but this is the image space similar to
what we talked about in adverts or
networks and this green shape is the
space of real-world images now if you
train a generator and generate some
images that look like this and these
images come from Stagg an from John
this distribution if the generator is
not good is not going to match the real
world distribution so our goal here is
to do something so that the red
distribution matches the real-world
distribution going to train the network
so that it realizes what we want so this
is our generator and it's what counts it
what what we want to train ultimately we
want to give it let's say a random
number or a random latent code of 100
dimension scalar numbers and we want it
to output an image but of course because
it's not trained initially it's going to
output a random image looks like
something like that
random pixels now this image doesn't
look very good
what we want is these images to look
like generated images that are very
similar to the real world so how are we
going to help this generator train it's
not like what we did in classic
supervised learning because we don't
have we don't really have inputs and
labels you know there is no label we
could maybe give it an image of a cat
and ask it to output another cat
but we want the network to be able to
output things that don't exist things
that we've never seen right so we want
the network to understand what a cat is
but not overfit to the cat we give it so
the way we're going to do it is through
a small game between this network called
the generator G and another network
called the discriminator D let's let's
look at how it works we have a database
of real images and we're going to start
with this distribution on the bottom
which is the real world data
distribution is the distribution of the
images in this database
now our generator has this distribution
initially it means the pixels that you
see here probably follow a distribution
that doesn't match the real world will
define a discriminator D and the goal of
the discriminator will be to detect if
an image is real or not so we're going
to give several images to discuss to
measure some
times we will give it generated images
and sometimes we will give it real-world
images what we want is that this
discriminator is a binary classifier
that outputs one if the image is real
and zero if the image was generated okay
so let's say we give it X coming from
the generated image it's going to give
us zero because we want the
discriminator to detect that X was
actually G of Z if the image came from
our database of real images we want the
discriminator to say one so it seems
like the discriminator would be easy to
train right it's just a binary
classification we can define a loss
function that is the binary
cross-entropy and the good thing is we
can have as many label as we want like
it's it's unsupervised but a little bit
supervised you know we have this
database and we label it all as one it's
just this image exists let's label them
as one for this creator and everything
that comes out of the generator let's
label it as zero for the discriminator
so basically data is not costly at all
in this point the way we will train is
that we will back propagate the gradient
to the discriminator to train the
discriminator using a binary croissant
roughly but what we ultimately want is
to train the generator that's what we
want at the end we're not going to use
the discriminator we just want to
generate images so we're going to direct
the gradient to go back to the generator
and why does this gradient go back to
the generator the reason is that X is G
of Z it means we can back propagate the
gradient all the way back to the input
of the discriminator but this input
depends on the input of the generator if
the image was generated so we can also
back propagate and direct the gradient
to the generator does it make sense
there is a direct relation between Z and
the last function in the case where the
image was generated if the image was
real then the generator couldn't get
degraded because X doesn't depend on Z
or on the features and parameters of the
generator ok so we would run an
algorithm such as ad
simultaneously on two many matches one
for the true data and from forms
generated data does this scheme make
sense to everyone
yeah one question so there's many method
of doing your question is about mixing
them in batches usually we would use we
would use one mini batch for the real
data and one mini batch for the fake
data but if in practice you can try
other things so there are many methods
that are being tried to train Gans
properly we're going to delve a little
more into the details of that when we
will see the loss functions so we hope
that the probability distributions will
match at the end and if it matches we're
going to just take the generator and
generate images normally it should be
able to generate images that look real
that look like they came from this
distribution okay sounds good so now
let's talk more about the training
procedure and try to figure out what the
loss function should be in this case
what should be the cost of the
discriminator
assuming assuming we give too many
batches one for real data so real images
and one for generated data that come
from G yes the same basic the same basic
loss function we use from binary class
for binary classifiers
it's true we're going to tweak it a tiny
bit but it's the same idea so this is
what it can look like we're going to
call it JD cost function of the
discriminator it has two terms what does
the first term say what does the second
term say and you can recognize the
binary croissant trophy here the only
difference is that we have a able that
is why real and a label that is why
generated in practice why real and why
generated are always going to be set to
values we know that Y generated is zero
and we know that Y real is one so we can
just remove these two terms because
they're both equal to 1 the first term
is telling us these should correctly
label real data as one - croissant
repeater the first term of a binary
cross-entropy the second term is going
to tell us this should correctly label
generated data 0 so the difference with
classic croissant roba we've seen is
that this summation is the summation
over the real mini batch and the
summation on the 2nd cross entropy is
the summation and generated mini batch
that make sense so we both want D to
correctly identify the real data and
also correctly identified fake data
that's why we have two terms now what
about the generator what do you think
should be the cost function of the
generator yes if I can put it either
that's from the generator I want to run
the first half
because I don't have any Wi-Fi and
inputs coming into generator yeah
exactly
yes but in your batch you will have had
like a certain number of real example of
certain dimmer of generating examples
the generated examples have no impact on
the first cross entre P and same for the
real examples on the second course on
true any other questions
okay so coming back to the cross to the
to the cost of the generator what should
it be this is a tiny bit complicated
let's move let's move on because we
don't have too much time the cost of the
generator basically should say that G
should try to swing it the goal is to
forge it to generate real samples and in
order to generate real samples we want
to fool D if J managed to fool D and D
is very good it means G is very good
right the problem is that it's a game
because if D is bad and G fools D it
doesn't mean that G is good because G
because D is bad it doesn't detect very
well the real versus fake examples we
want D to go up to be very good and G to
go up at the same time until the
equilibrium is reached at a certain
point where D will always output one
half like random probabilities because
it cannot distinguish the samples coming
from G versus the real samples so this
cost function is basically saying for
generated images we want to classify
them as one okay so you know like if
you're using so how to implement that if
you're using a different framework
you've been building a graph right and
at the end of your graph you've been
building your cost functions D that is
very close to a binary cross-entropy
what you're going to just do is to
define a node that is going to be minus
the cost function of D it's going every
time you're going to call the function J
of G is going to run the graph
that you define for JFD and run a an
opposition operation an opposite of
operation same way propagate gradients
back the same way we're not going to
propagate the same way we're going to
turn into a minus sign for the grade for
the generator so you know you you back
propagate on the on the on D and when
you back propagate on G you would flip
you would flip the sign that's all we do
the same thing with the sign fleet terms
of implementation is just another
operation okay now let's look at
something interesting is that this Lord
logarithm let's look at the graph of the
logarithm so I'm going to plot against
the abscess axe G sorry D of G of Z so
what does this mean this axis is the
output of D when given a generated
example G of Z is going to be between 0
and 1 because it's a probability D is a
binary classifier with a sigmoid our
output probably if we plot logarithm of
X so like this type of thing this would
be log of the of G of Z does it make
sense is the logarithm function if I
plot minus that minus that so let me let
me plot minus logarithm of G of G Ozzy
or or let me let me do something else
let me plot logarithm of minus D of G of
Z
this is it do you guys agree now what
I'm going to do is that I'm going to
plot another function that is this one
that is logarithm of one minus D of G of
Z okay so the question is right now what
we're doing is that we're saying the
cost function of the generator is
logarithm of one minus D of G of Z so it
looks like this right it looks like this
one what's the issue with this one what
do you think is the issue with this cost
function looking at it like that sorry
can you say louder it goes to negative
infinity in one that's what you mean
yeah yeah and so the consequence of that
is that the gradient here is going to be
very large the closer we go to one but
the closer we are to zero the lower is
the gradient and is the reverse
phenomenon for this logarithm the
gradient is very high and very high I
mean in absolute value a very high when
we're close to zero but it's very low
when we go close to one okay so which
loss function you think would be better
a loss function that looks like this one
or a loss function that looks like this
one
to train our generator
the broader question is where are we
early in the training are we close to
here or always close to death what does
it mean to be close they're two to one
you're fooling the network it means that
the kinks that generated samples or real
you're here this place is the contrary
he thinks that generated samples are
fake
it means correctly finds out that
they're fake early on we're generally
here because the discriminator is better
than the generator generator output
garbage at the beginning and it's very
easy for the discriminator to figure out
that it's fake because this garbage
looks very different from real-world
data so early on we're here
so which function is the best one to to
to to be our cost yeah so probably this
one is better so we have to use a
mathematical trick to change this into
that right and the mathematical trick is
pretty standard right now we're
minimizing something that is in log of 1
minus X we can say that doing so is the
same as maximizing something that is in
log of X near a simple flip min max flip
and we can also say that it's the same
as minimizing something in minus log of
X does it make sense so we're going to
use this mathematical trick to convert
our function that is a saturating cost
we would say into an on-stage rating
class that is going to look more like
this let's see what it looks like so to
sum up our cost function currently looks
like that
it's a saturating cost because early on
the gradients are small we cannot train
G we're going to do a flip that I just
talked about on the board and convert
this into another function that is a non
saturating cost ok what you yeah
so the reason it's the blue one is like
that is because I added a minus sign
here so I'm flipping this okay and it's
the same thing it's just the sign of the
gradient that is going to be different
like that the gradient is high at the
beginning and low at the end that makes
sense so we're going to do the use this
flip and so we have a new training
processor now where J of D didn't change
but J of G changed we have a minus sign
here and instead of the log of 1 minus D
of G of Z we have the log of G of G of Z
does that make sense to everyone cool
and actually so this is a fun thing if
you should check this paper which is
really cool Oregon's created equal it's
a large study of many many different
guns
it shows what people have tried and you
can see that people have tried all types
of laws to make guns trainable so it
looks it looks complicated here but
actually the mm gun is the first one we
saw together is the minimax lost
function the second one is the non
saturating one that we just see so you
see between the first two the only
difference is that on the generator we
get the log of 1 minus D of X hat
becoming law of minus log of D of X I
okay now another trick to train guns is
to use the fact that a non saturating to
use the fact that D is usually easier to
train than G but as the improved G can
improve if D doesn't improve G cannot
improve so you can see the the
performance of D has an upper bound to
what G can achieve because of that we
will usually train D more time than we
will train G so we will basically train
for nomination K times D 1 time G K
times D 1 times e and so on so that the
discriminator becomes better then the
generator can catch up better then can
catch up and so on that make sense
there's also methods to use like
different learning rates for D ng
to take this into account to train
faster the discriminator okay because we
don't have too much time I'm going to
skip the bathroom Wiggins we're going to
sit probably next week together after
you guys have seen the bathroom videos
okay great school so just to sum up some
some tips to Train ganz is to modify the
cost function we've seen one
modification there are many more keeping
D up to date with respect to G so
updating D more than you update g using
virtual match norm which is a derivate
of batch norm so it's a different type
of action or is used here and something
called one-sided lai label smoothing
that i'm not going to talk about it
today because we don't have time so
let's see some nice result now and
that's the funnest part so some of you
have worked with word embeddings and you
you might know that we're done weddings
are vectors that can encode the meaning
of the word and you can compute
operation sometimes on this on these
words so if you take if you take king -
quinn it should be equal to mine - woman
operations like that that happen in the
space of encoding so here's the same you
can use a generator to generate faces
and the paper is listed on the bottom
here so you give a code that is a random
code and it will give you an image of a
face you can give it a second code it's
going to give you a second image that is
different from the first one because the
code was different you can give it a
third one it's going to give you a third
interface the fun part is if you take
code 1 - code 2 plus code 3 so basically
image of a man with glasses - image of a
man plus image of the women will give
you an image of a woman with glasses
so this is interesting because it means
that linear operation in the latent
space of codes have impact directly on
the image space okay let's look at
something even better so you can use
guns for image generation of course
these are very nice samples you see that
sometimes guns have problem with with oh
no I don't think that's the dog but but
but these are stag and plus vs. is a
very impressive gun that has generated
that has been state of the art for a
long time okay so let's see something
fun something called image to image
translation so actually the the project
winners last quarter in spring was a
project dealing with exactly that
generating satellite images based on the
map image so given a map image generate
the satellite image using a gun so you
see that instead of giving a latent code
that was 100 dimensional you could give
a very detailed code the code can be
this image right and you have to find a
way to constrain your network in a
certain width in a certain way to push
it to output exactly the satellite image
that corresponds it to this map image
there are many other results that are
found converting zebras to horses to
zebras and zebras to horses and apples
to oranges and oranges to Apple so let's
do a case study together let's say our
goal is to convert horses to zebras on
images and vice versa can you tell me
what data we need let's go quickly so
that we have some time yeah horses and
zebras do you need her images you know
like you need to have the same image of
your horse as a zebra yeah so the
problem is okay we could have labels
images you know like a horse and it's
zebra doppelganger in the same position
and we could train a network to take one
and out with the other unfortunately we
don't not every horse has a doppelganger
that is a zebra so we cannot do that so
instead we're going to do unpaired
unpaired generative address or networks
it means we have a database of horses
and a database of zebras but these are
different horses and different zebras
they're not one-to-one there's no one to
one mapping between them there's no
mapping at all what architecture do you
want to use nice not really ok so let's
see about the architecture and the cost
so I'm gonna go over it quickly because
it's a it's a very fun gun with its
called cycle gun so the way we're going
to work it out is we have a horse called
capital H we want to generate the zebra
version of this horse right so we give
it to a generator that we call g1
you can call it h to Z like horse to
zebra it should give us this horse H as
a zebra right and in fact if we're
training again we need a discriminator
so we will add a discriminator that is
going to be a binary classifier to tell
us if this image outputted by generator
1 is real or not
so this discriminator is going to take
in some images of zebras probably or yes
zebras or horses and it's going to also
take the generated images I'm going to
see which one is fake which one is real
on the other hand we're going to do and
the vice-versa is very important we need
to enforce the fact that this horse G 1
of H should be the same horse as H in
order to do that we're going to create
another generator which is going to take
the generated image and generate back
the input image and this is where we
will be able to enforce the constraints
that G 2 of G 1 of H should be equal to
H do you see why this loop is super
important because if we don't have this
loop we don't have the constraints on
the fact that the horse should be the
the zebra should be the horse as a zebra
the same horse as H so we'll do that and
we have a second discriminator to decide
if this image is real this is one step H
to Z
another state might be z2h where we
start with the zebra give it to
generator to generate the horse version
of the zebra discriminate generate back
the zebra version of the zebra and this
commit
does that make sense so this is the
general pattern used in cycle Gans and
what I'd like to go over is what loss
should we minimize in order to unforce
the fact that we want the horse to be
converted to a zebra that is the same as
the horse and someone gives me the terms
that we need someone wants to give it a
try
go for two minutes
yes you want to make sure that the
picture in the end that is a zebra that
you sure talk with matches the secret
that you started with or the horse -
shirt off with matches of course that
you had immediately okay same time you
also need to have discriminator -
identifying that the image is a real
zebra or real horse yeah because you
don't want it to just sort of input in
the sampled image and then output back
to you the same okay so okay that's
great so you're saying we need the
classic cost functions that we've seen
previously plus another one that is the
matching between H and G - of G 1 of H
and Z and G 1 of g12c correct so we'll
have all these terms one term to Train
d1 which is the classic term we've seen
differentiate real images from generated
images g1 as well same we were using the
non saturating cost on generate images
same for D - same for G - these are
classics the one we need to add to all
of this is the cycle cost which is the
distance between this term g2 of G 1 of
H and H and the same thing for zebras
does that make sense so you have the
intuition to build that type of losses
we just sum everything and gives us the
cost function we're looking for the same
cost function for d1 and d2 yeah so the
you could but it's not going to work
that well I think so I think there is a
there's a tiny mistake here is that the
zi here the small zi should be small H I
and the small H ion top should be a
small C eye because the discriminator
one is going to receive generated
samples that look like zebras because it
came out of g1 so you want the real
database that you give it to to be
zebras as well to force to force the
generator want to output things that
look like zebras and vice-versa for the
second one okay
and this is my favorite so you can
convert the ROM into a face and back to
a ramen is the most fun application I
found is from Naruto me at all
antic we attack oh so it's Japanese
research lab were working hard to do
face to ramen yeah and actually in two
in two to three weeks you will learn
object detection you know to detect
faces and if you learn that maybe you
can start a project to like detect a
face and then replace it by a ramen
because also funny funny work by Naruto
me okay oh this is a super cool
application as well so let's look at
that okay so we have so this model is a
conditional gun that was conditioned on
learning learning edges and generating
cuts based on the edges so I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to draw a cat sorry I cannot
see again I'm not a good driver
it's the cat okay he's going down with
the model I hope it's gonna work
okay I don't think it works but it's
supposed to work
so you can generate cats baits on on
edges and you can do it for different
things you can do it for a shoe so all
these model have been trained for that
okay
yes go for it
straighten your feet you have to train
it specifically for the domain so like
these models are different swing of the
13 train okay looking for my
presentation I missed it the
presentation disappeared okay
another application is super resolution
you can give a lower resolution image
and generate the super resolution
version of it using guns and this is
pretty cool because you can get a high
resolution image downsample it and use
this as the minimax game you know like
you have the high resolution version of
the lower very lower resolution image
other applications can be
privacy-preserving so some people have
been working on you know in medical in
the medical space privacy is a huge
issue you cannot share data set among
hospitals among medical teams is common
so people have been looking at
generating a data set that looks like a
medical data set if you train a model on
this data set is going to give you the
same type of parameters than the other
one but this data set is anonymized
so they can share the anonymized data
with each other
and train their models and that without
being able to access the information of
the
patient and who is manufacturing is
important as well so Gans can generate
very specific objects that can replace
bones for humans personalized - - to the
human body so same for dental if you
lose the teeth the the technician can
take a picture and decide what the the
crown should look like the gun can
generate it another topic is how to
evaluate guns you know you might say we
can just look at the images and see if
they look real and it will give us an
idea if the gun is working well in
practice it's hard because maybe the
images you're looking at or overfitting
images from the real samples you gave to
the to the to the discriminator so how
do you check that it's very complicated
so human annotation is a big one where
you would you would build a software
push it on the cloud and people around
the world are going to select which
images look generated which images look
not generated to see if a human can can
can compare your gun to real-world data
and how your gun performs so it would
look like that a web app indicates which
image is fake which image is real you
can you can do different experiments
like you can show very quickly an image
for a fraction of a second and ask them
was it real or not or you can give them
unlimited time different experiments can
be led there's another one that is more
scalable because the human annotation is
very painful you know every time you
train again you want to do that to
verify if the gun is working well takes
a lot of time so instead of using humans
why don't we use a very good network
that is good at classification in fact
in fact the inception network is a
tremendous network that does
classification we're going to give our
image samples to this inception network
and see what the network thinks of this
image does it think that it's a dog or
not does it look like a dog for the
network or not and we can scale it and
make it very quick and there is a
inception score that that we can talk
next week about when we will have time
it measures the quality of the samples
and also it measures the diversity of
the sample I'll go over it next week
there's another distance that is very
popular that has been growing ly popular
recently called the fresh inception
distance and I advise you to check some
of this paper to more interested in it
for for your projects so just to end for
next Wednesday we'll have C 2 & 3 and
also the whole C 3 modules you'll have 3
quizzes be careful these two quiz C 3 M
1 and C 3 M 2 or longer than the normal
quizzes there are like wild case studies
so take your time and go over it and
you'll have 1 programming assignments
make sure you understand the batch norm
videos so that we can go over the
virtual batch norm hopefully next week
together and hands-on section this
Friday you will receive your project
proposal as soon as possible and meet
with your project TAS to go over the
proposal and to make decisions regarding
the next steps for your projects I'll
stick around in case you have any
questions ok thanks guys